mind your decisions I'm presh tal Walker
quadratic equations are a standard topic
in algebra class you probably learn to
solve them using Brahma Gupta's
quadratic formula which has been known
for nearly 1400 years X is equal to the
opposite of B plus or minus the square
root of b squared minus 4ac all over 2a
students are typically taught to
memorize this formula but some students
struggle with the formula and it would
be nice to have another intuitive way
the story is not over yet news outlets
today are talking about a new way to
make quadratic equations easy the method
comes from potion lo who writes about a
different way to solve quadratic
equations as written on the website the
individual steps have been discovered by
ancient mathematicians but the
combination of the steps is not commonly
known for those that don't know potion
Lo has math degrees from Caltech
Cambridge and Princeton he's also a
professor at Carnegie Mellon University
and he's the coach of the u.s.
mathematical Olympiad team he coats the
team to its first ever back-to-back
number one ranked victories in 2015 and
2016
and he coach them to their second ever
back-to-back number one ranked victories
in 2018 and 2019 if professor Lowe is
suggesting a problem solving method it
is definitely worth trying before we get
to the method let's do a motivating
example x squared minus 8x plus 15 is
equal to zero we'll solve this by the
method of factoring we want to find two
numbers such that their product is 15
and their sum is equal to 8 we can do
this by considering the factors of 15 we
readily get to numbers of 3 and 5
therefore we can factor the original
equation and we'll get two solutions of
3 and 5 students are taught this method
the question is can we generalize the
idea let's consider a general quadratic
equation the first thing we'll do is
we'll divide both sides by a this will
make the coefficient of x squared equal
to 1 then we will write cap
be for the coefficient on X and capital
C for the constant term we can write any
quadratic equation as x squared plus
capital BX plus C is equal to 0 so let's
try solving this by factoring we want
two numbers such that their product is
equal to C and their sum is equal to
negative B if we could do that we could
factor the equation and we would have
our two roots but how can we do that
well if we have a sum of negative B
that's the same thing as saying we want
an average of negative B over two for
two numbers we would then want to see if
those numbers have a product of C now in
class we typically consider C and look
for factors and then see which factors
have the sum of negative B a key insight
in this method is to flip this process
around let's consider the sum and then
try and work out the product so we want
two numbers that have an average of
negative B over two these can take the
form negative B over two plus some
increment C and negative B over two
minus some increment C we then multiply
these together and set them equal to C
this is nice because we have a
convenient formula here it's a
difference of squares we have B squared
over 4 minus Z squared and that's equal
to C we can then readily solve this
equation for Z and then we have some
candidates we have these two numbers for
X and what's nice is that we've actually
found two numbers that have an average
of negative B over 2 and we found two
numbers that have a product of C
therefore these do satisfy what we need
we could factor the equation and we have
found solutions so these are the
relevant formulas and a similar thing
like this is taught in Germany but a key
insight in this method is that you don't
have to memorize anything the method is
to consider values negative B over 2
plus or minus Z and then solve for C by
setting the product of these two values
equal to C so let's take the original
equation x squared minus 8x plus 15 is
equal to zero we want to consider two
values that have an average of negative
B over 2 which is an average of 4 so we
want 4 plus Z and 4 minus C we want
their product to be equal to 15 we take
the product of these and will be a
difference of squares 4 squared minus Z
squared is equal to 15 we can readily
solve this equation and get Z is equal
to plus or minus 1 we then take plus or
minus 1 from negative B over 2 so we
have 4 minus 1 which is equal to 3 and
we have 4 plus 1 which is equal to 5 and
these are the two values we found
earlier when we were solving this
equation let's now consider an example
that's harder to factor x squared minus
4x plus 6 is equal to 0 we want the two
values to be negative B over 2 plus or
minus Z negative B over 2 is equal to 2
so we have 2 plus Z and 2 minus Z we
then take their product and set that
equal to 6 this works out to be a
difference of squares 2 squared minus Z
squared is equal to 6
we then readily solve for Z squared and
that's equal to negative 2 taking the
square root of both sides we get Z is
equal to plus or minus I times the
square root of 2 we thus have the two
values 2 plus I root 2 and 2 minus I
root 2 these two values do have the
proper sum and the proper product
therefore their roots to the original
equation we can compactly write them as
2 plus or minus I root 2
let's do a final example 2x squared
minus 4x plus 10 is equal to 0 the first
thing to notice is the coefficient on x
squared is equal to 2 well divide the
entire equation by 2 to make sure it's
equal to 1 we have x squared minus 2x
plus 5 is equal to 0 now we'll solve as
before negative B over 2 is equal to 1
so a 1 plus C and 1 minus C we want to
multiply these together to get a product
of 5 we'll do some simplification and
we'll solve that Z is equal to plus or
minus 2i therefore we have the values of
1 plus or minus 2i these have the proper
sum and the proper product and therefore
they are roots to the original equation
so now let's recap we start with the
general quadratic equation and we'll
divide it by a if needed so that the
coefficient on x squared is equal to 1
we'll end up with a quadratic equation
that will be x squared plus capital BX
plus C is equal to 0 we then consider
values of negative B over 2 plus or
minus Z and then we'll solve for Z by
setting the product equal to C we will
thus end up with two numbers that have
the proper sum and the proper product
and therefore there will be roots to the
original quadratic equation what I
described is the idea of the method for
a formal description I highly recommend
you check out potion lows website he
gives a history of the steps and a
precise explanation of why each step is
mathematically justified do check it out
finally I want to thank professor Lowe
for providing feedback to an earlier
draft of the video I think this method
could be very useful for many students
around the world you should definitely
give it a try thanks for making mind
your decisions one of the best channels
on YouTube as always thanks for watching
and thanks for your support
[Music]